whether i live to 80 or 150  what's more important is  how i'm showing up every day for those  around me where you put your energy and  attention and how you behave with  yourself and with others  are heirlooms in the making  that becomes my legacy because it gives  meaning to my day to day but it also  allows me to live in such a way that i  know i'm doing what i can that we are  setting up every generation successfully  to live a better more flourishing  psychologically mentally spiritual life  than what we came into our  moment-to-moment actions are the  firewall  from having a world dissolve into one of  kind of anger and bitterness as opposed  to kind of one of human flourishing and  love